Our company has a new strategic initiative to increase market penetration,...
...maximize brand loyalty, and enhance intangible assets.
In pursuit of these objectives,...
...we've started a new project for which we require seven red lines.
I understand your company can help us in this matter.
Of course!
Walter here will be the project manager.
Walter, we can do this, can't we?
Yes, of course.
Anderson here is our expert in all matters related to drawing red lines.
We've brought him along today to share his professional opinion.
Nice to meet you!
Well, you all know me.
This is Justine, our company's design specialist.
Hello!
We need you to draw seven red lines,...
...all of them strictly perpendicular.
Some with green ink and some with transparent.
Can you do that?
I'll simplify.
A line as such can be drawn with absolutely any ink,...
...but if you want to get a red line, you need to use red ink.
What if we draw them with blue ink?
It still won't work.
If you use blue ink, you will get blue lines.